le harcèlement scolaire est encore fait
une victime un lycéen de 15 ans a été
retrouvé pendu dans sa chambre à Poissy
ce mardi 5 septembre cette adolescent
avait été victime de harcèlement dans
son établissement scolaire l'an dernier
lorsqu'il était en 3e prépa métier au
lycée professionnel Adrienne Bolland de
Poissy une enquête a été ouverte en
recherche des causes de la mort l'ado
avait signalé en décembre 2022 des
brimades et injures répétées de la part
de plusieurs élèves trois mois plus tard
en mars 2023 ses parents et les élèves
concernés ont été reçus par
l'établissement mais le mois suivant
dans un courrier au lycée la famille a
dénoncé l'absence de mesure suffisante
prise le lycée lui assure que le jeune
garçon a bénéficié d'un suivi régulier
avec le CPE en cette rentrée 2023 il
avait changé d'établissement et était
désormais scolarisé à Paris chaque drame
est un drame de trop qui nous rappelle
que nous ne sommes toujours pas à la
hauteur Dina dans le Haut-Rhin en
octobre 2021 Lucas dans les Vosges en
janvier 2023 ou encore l'Insee dans le
Pas-de-Calais en mai 2023 les suicides
d'adolescents se sont multipliés ce qui
a poussé l'éducation nationale à tenter
de renforcer les mesures entières
seulement comme permettre le changement
d'établissement d'un élève harceleur en
dernier recours dans son discours de
rentrée le 28 août Gabriel Attal avait
assuré que la lutte contre le
harcèlement serait la grande cause de
l'année scolaire 2023-2024
[Musique]